a snapshot of an ordinary day in Moscow
people go about their business hardly
paying any attention to the robots
navigating the streets come rain of
shine these six wheeled devices deliver
documents parcels and food from
companies supermarkets and
restaurants this is the third generation
of our robots they move easily in the
snow and navigate in the rain they are
not bothered by temperatures from 30° to
30 plus de C the ordering process takes
just a couple of minutes using an app
after which the robot H the treats a 3D
map installed in their brain prevents
them from getting lost and electronic
eyes help overcome obstacles something
that sometimes might prove to be quite
challenging in the adverse Russian
weather videos of people trying to help
a delivery robot out of a snow drift
have gone viral online
manufacturers are confident the cost of
delivery by humans and their robots will
be equal in the near future therefore it
opens more business prospects for the
project environmental concerns were a
driving force behind these electric
faeries launched in mid 2023 they've
become part of moscow's public transport
alongside regular buses trams and the
Metro
as you know in Winter the Moscow River
freezes so these year round electric
fairies are capable of breaking a 20 cm
thick layer of ice all the Technologies
we use here are domestic
ones the faeries can carry 50 passengers
for Journey and offer USB charges and
Wi-Fi access authorities say they
produce no harmful emissions and
although their relatively sedate Pace
makes them rather unsuitable for the
daily commute to work they have proved
popular with
tourists another machine designed for an
urban landscape is pixel a multi-roll
andm cleaner for closed venues such as
parks and
museums we are joking we've managed to
merge something that seemed impossible
to combine our pixel robot is a
collaboration between it Specialists and
utility
workers the robot can work 24 hours a
day with brakes for recharging and
refilling with water in summer or for
defrosting liquids in Winter it can be
controlled remotely or operate
autonomously these AI Solutions can make
people's lives much easier but there's
also a flip side to their increased use
since Russia launched its so-called
special military operation in Ukraine
nearly 2 years ago thousands of Migrant
laborers have left the country the local
currency the rubble has gradually
depreciated and working conditions have
deteriorated
prompting innovators to Fast Track AI
technology to partially supplement the
human Workforce Julia shabala Al jazer
Moscow make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer